[Music]
on this monday night a tougher crackdown
at canada's borders
what the federal government is
considering to further restrict travel
and keep more contagious coronavirus
variants
out we're looking at that very actively
right now
plus the protection the moderna vaccine
provides now and
how the company is bracing for more
mutations by
america u.s president biden's plan to
pump up his country's economy
grounded israel's new ban on flights and
the exceptions
and one very long year of covid19
in canada the plan should have been we
locked down
the lessons learned and how science has
[Music]
global evolved with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is january 25th
2021 exactly one year since a single
story
began to dominate the headlines
coronavirus
confirmed in canada one official case
another presumptive case
their connection this new case isn't
surprising
plus new questions over how the virus
spreads
now it's one year later after more than
nineteen
thousand canadians have died of covid19
and there are still questions about how
it spreads
and mutates the most urgent concern
right now those highly contagious new
variants which spread
much faster it's not known how prevalent
those variants are in canada finding
them requires genomic sequencing and not
every positive case
goes through that a handful of cases of
the variant first detected in south
africa
have been confirmed in canada so have
dozens of cases of the one first
discovered in the uk in ontario 34
people are known to be infected with the
uk variant now and it's feared
it is present in a second ontario
long-term care
facility in alberta it was confirmed
today there are now
20 cases of the uk variant 19 of them
are known to have a connection to travel
one does not that is an indication it is
spreading in the community
which the health minister said today is
very concerning
here's what could happen new modeling
from simon fraser university suggests
if a more contagious variant takes hold
in the community the situation
could lead to a sharp spike in cases
that red line
sfu researchers say tougher measures are
needed including stricter travel rules
to prevent
a looming disaster the federal
government is considering imposing new
measures to restrict who comes into
canada
and to discourage non-essential travel
michael couture is following that
tonight plus the latest on the delay in
vaccines
mike well donna government sources tell
global news the liberals are looking at
ways to tighten up the canadian border
to outside travelers now the emergencies
act is still on the table
and we're hearing new measures to limit
incoming travel
could be coming very soon i also
encourage the the prime minister
close down any travel coming into canada
outside of
residents of canada ontario premier doug
ford
couldn't be more clear he's worried that
without a hard border closure
too many cases of covid 19 and its
variants
are coming into canada so if i'm doing
my math correctly two point five percent
of thirty thousand seven hundred fifty
people
slipping in through the border that have
covet there is already a requirement for
travelers to have a negative covet 19
result before
getting on a flight for canada but the
deputy prime minister
is hinting more is coming our government
absolutely is looking seriously and
carefully
at measures to further
guarantee the toughness
of our border measures the ndp says it's
willing to work with the liberals on a
forced quarantine like australia
there people must stay in a hotel for 14
days upon arrival
a move that could be necessary as the
virus spreads
and the flow of vaccines has dried up
for this week
next week our order has been cut by 86
percent
the opposition hammered the government
on the lack of pfizer biontech vaccine
deliveries
it's caused by retooling at the plant in
belgium
but the opposition wants to know why
other supplies are off limits
there are vaccines being made not far
from us in kalamazoo michigan did the
prime minister ask
for the ability to have that plant used
the government says doses made at the
american plant are earmarked for the u.s
in the first quarter of this year and
they maintain
canada will have the full order of 4
million doses
by the end of march donna
michael couture in ottawa thanks a big
question is how effective are the
vaccines against the variants
modernist said today its vaccine appears
to work against the variant from the uk
once both doses have been given it also
protects against the south african
variant
but a booster shot may be required
crystal commancing on what we know so
far about the vaccines
and the variants
when it comes to fighting covid19 your
system needs neutralizing antibodies
vaccines deliver the code to build them
the code delivered in the modernicovid19
vaccine
is less effective against the south
african strain
a study by the drug companies suggests
the vaccine's effectiveness
is reduced roughly six-fold however when
it comes to the uk
variant the vaccine produces the same
level of neutralizing antibodies
we see very high level of antibody with
a
b117 strength from the uk
health officials in multiple countries
say the data is helpful
but does not change the current
recommendations
for the purposes of the vaccine rollout
whether you
whether people have had the old or the
new variant it doesn't matter
what you need to do is get vaccinated
when the call comes
there seems to be a considerable more
threat
to vaccine efficacy even though the
cushion
of efficacy is sound enough that the
vaccines that we're using now
will be good against both the mutant in
south africa as well as in the uk
if any country bets everything on the
vaccine we're going to lose
that's the bottom line the vaccine is
one tool
moderna is working on a booster shot
based off of the south african variant
there are also other vaccines and trials
and new therapies being studied i think
we're going to be going into a period
where we'll want to be seeing
even more collaboration across producers
to try and then together look at how do
we
both assess the the the changing
environment we're in
an environment made all the more
challenging with the continued
and rapid spread of the virus krystal
gavinson global news
london the ceo of great canadian gaming
corporation has resigned after
accusations he and his wife traveled
from vancouver to yukon
to get the covet 19 vaccine 55 year old
rod baker
and 32 year old ekaterina baker were
charged and ticketed in white horse on
thursday
the couple was required by territorial
law to isolate for 14
days when they arrived it's alleged they
instead
chartered a private plane to a remote
community and received the modern
vaccine they reportedly claimed to be
employees
of a local motel they were both fined
over one thousand dollars each
baker resigned from his casino job on
sunday
the bc government has released a
long-awaited report into how that
province handled the covid19 outbreaks
in long-term care homes
it was commissioned last summer critics
say it took too long to be made public
and say the recommendations have yet to
be implemented robin gill
reports the first death from covet 19
in british columbia was at this
long-term care home in north vancouver
since then there have been more than 262
outbreaks at care facilities
that have led to 72 percent of pandemic
deaths in the province
if you look for a theme through this
you'll see there's a lack of
coordination
and consistent communication and
that has always been an issue that
response from the head of the bc
care providers association in response
to a report commissioned by the bc
government on how it guided long-term
care homes
among the findings there was no
coordination in planning
sourcing purchasing and distribution of
ppe
there were inconsistent messages on how
to isolate positive patients
there was inconsistent infection control
across care homes
and while it was the right thing for the
public health officer to order staff to
work in one facility to control the
spread
to other facilities it left staff
shortages
elsewhere we are learning as we go
and we know of course that this virus is
transmitted through people
and it is very challenging for us to
know
when people are incubating the disease
and when they can transmit it to others
now bc is in the midst of a second wave
have lessons been learned and changes
made the health minister insists yes
but kovitt is still here what's happened
in november and december
and now january january in this second
wave of covet 19 is significantly more
community transmission and that reflects
in long-term care clearly um you know
this report has not been implemented
because
many of these same issues
are still there if there's one lesson
from this pandemic it's that the vicious
virus knows
its target the vulnerable robin gill
global news vancouver
lynn bayak the senator who defended
canada's residential school system has
announced her retirement
bayak was facing an imminent vote on a
motion which sought to make her the
first ever senator to be ejected from
the red chamber
citing individual racism she has argued
residential schools were well
intentioned and she was kicked out of
the conservative caucus
for publishing racist letters against
indigenous people
on her website and brampton mp ramesh
sangha has been removed from the federal
liberal caucus in a statement the chief
government whip says sangha was removed
after making
baseless and dangerous accusations
against a number of his caucus
colleagues
global news has asked for details of
those accusations
none have been provided in washington
the american president joe biden signed
a buy
american executive order today it
directs government agencies to
strengthen requirements about purchasing
products and services from the u.s
busines from u.s businesses rather and
it boosts the level of us-made content a
project would need to qualify as made in
america
that could make it harder for canadian
companies the order also applies more
stringent standards to hard-won
exceptions canada secured to the rules
imposed by
former president barack obama
also in washington the impeachment case
against former president trump is
inching closer to a trial in the senate
late today a procession of house members
carried the article of impeachment
to the senate trump was impeached for a
second time
january 13th charging him with
incitement to insurrection
trump is already out of office of course
so why proceed with this next step
in the senate jackson proskow explains
the moment that nearly shattered
democracy
will be the focus of the historic
post-presidential impeachment trial of
donald trump
he tried to kill american democracy
there isn't any doubt about that
trump was impeached by the house for
incitement of insurrection
you'll never take back our country with
weakness
now a senate trial which would normally
seek to remove a sitting president
will instead aim to disqualify trump
from holding public office in the future
if you were somehow or other to to
secure a second win as president
president united states american
democracy would be dead in any form uh
that
we would recognize it it will take all
50 democrats and at least 17
republicans in the senate to convict
trump a tall order even with senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell leaving
the door open
the mob was fed lies
they were provoked by the president and
other
powerful people trump still has plenty
of allies
we already have a flaming fire in this
country and it's like taking a bunch of
gasoline and pouring it on top of the
fire the trial won't start for two weeks
an eternity in politics leaving time for
other damaging evidence to emerge
like reports trump considered firing the
acting attorney general
in a bid to press the department of
justice to intervene and overturn the
election
there are concerns the trial will serve
as another flash point for violent
pro-trump extremists
the fences and seven thousand members of
the national guard
are being kept in washington until it's
over and while all that's going on
there's mounting legal trouble for
trump's allies dominion voting systems
which was thrust into the center of
trump's election conspiracies
has filed suit against rudy giuliani
trump's lawyer
seeking 1.3 billion dollars in damages
for what it calls a viral disinformation
campaign
donna jackson proskow in washington
thanks
the other executive order president
biden signed today repeals the ban on
transgender people serving openly
in the u.s military all right
thank you it reverses a ban former
president trump ordered during his first
year in office
biden tweeted today america is safer
when everyone qualified to serve
can do so openly and with pride
anger erupts over pandemic restrictions
coming up the outrage in parts of israel
and the netherlands
israel has banned most flights in and
out of the country to try to keep out
more cases of the highly contagious
kovid 19 variants
the ban is in effect for at least one
week exceptions will be made for things
like
cargo funerals and humanitarian needs
prime minister benjamin netanyahu says a
rising number of highly transmissible
variants have been detected
israel is in the midst of a third
nationwide lockdown and it has the
world's most ambitious vaccination
campaign
more than 25 percent of israelis have
received at least one dose
palestinians in the west bank and gaza
are not included in israel's vaccine
rollout
ultra-orthodox protesters angry about
lockdown measures set a bus on fire last
night in a suburb of tel aviv
the mob beat the driver who says he
survived by the skin of his teeth
ultra-orthodox communities in israel
have resisted shutting down their
schools yeshivas and synagogues
and some young extremists have violently
taken matters
into their own hands in amsterdam more
than 100 people have been arrested after
weekend protests they defied a ban on
public gatherings and
a new curfew
police fired a water cannon and used
tear gas angry demonstrations erupted on
saturday after the dutch government
opposed its first
nighttime curfew since the end of the
second world war
residents must be in their homes between
9 00 p.m and 4 30 a.m
or face fines the country's case numbers
have been dropping over the past month
but the government fears kobed 19
variants
could lead to a surge in new cases
can those who beat the virus bend the
pandemic's rules ahead experts answer
your kovid 19 questions
you're watching global national
we've learned a great deal about covid19
in the last year but new questions keep
emerging
and so we still have our jeff simple on
the case
trying to get answers for you from the
experts
the approach that we're taking allowed
us to identify this patient immediately
exactly one year since canada confirmed
its first case of covid19
some are wondering whether they might
have been infected even earlier
carol writes i think i had covid19 in
january 2020 but was never tested
it could have been influenza or another
respiratory virus
this infectious disease specialist
believes she had the virus back in march
but was also
never tested though she says cases in
february and january last year are less
likely
after canada's first case doctors began
testing some patients
but by the end of february had only
identified a dozen infections
and the first confirmed community spread
wasn't until march
but if you want to be sure some private
clinics now offer
antibody tests you know the question
that i'd like to answer is
uh is there any planning underway with
the public health
effort to take into account
the number of people that who are now
immune
some countries are considering so-called
immunity passports for those who've
recovered from covid
iceland for example now allows travelers
with proof of prior infection
to visit without quarantine but canada
has no plans to follow suit
since we don't really know how long the
natural immunity
for kovid will ask i was just wondering
about
wearing masks outside in the winter with
covent uh
i would i'd heard that cova germs don't
dissipate as quickly as they do in the
summer
she's right respiratory droplets fall
faster
in hot humidity than they do in the cold
dry winter
it becomes a lighter and lighter droplet
and that can float around
but the extent to which that raises the
risk of infection
is a matter of debate i think cold
temperatures
or warm temperatures mostly irrelevant
if you're outdoors and you're physically
distant from others
the likelihood of getting this infection
is
exceedingly rare but in a canadian
winter
masking up outdoors can't hurt and can
help provide a layer of protection
not to mention a face warmer jeff semple
global news toronto
coveted in canada one year later next
what we've learned
and what we have not
this is an anniversary we'd certainly
rather not be marking
since the first case of covet 19 was
confirmed in canada one year ago
public health experts have repeatedly
told us this is a marathon not a sprint
but even marathons have a finish line
this virus has always
been a step ahead of us eric sorenson
reflects
on a year of covid in canada
it was the first presumptive case of
covet 19 in canada
a man returning from wuhan china was
hospitalized at toronto's sunnybrook
hospital
the patient was detected and immediately
put
in isolation but could covet health and
government officials have been more
tightly bunched to talk about it
how little we knew then of the coming
threat the risk to ontarians is still
low
and things are managed and well
controlled
for weeks it seemed well controlled
there were very few cases but canadians
continued to travel carefree
still gathered in huge crowds and we're
told there was seldom a need for masks
in public
what we worry about is actually the
potential
negative aspects of wearing masks this
mask is a wonderful example of this this
epidemiologist says advice
evolved over time on masks from limited
to widespread use
but it's not evidence that science got
it wrong it's completely acceptable
to modify your opinion based on new
information
that's how science works like you modify
your opinion based on
fact and based on emerging data canada
has advised canadians to curtail
non-essential international travel by
the time the country began to lock down
last march
the response was remarkable governments
at all levels and most canadians readily
accepted a dramatic shutdown in their
lives
but over time businesses reopened
canadians began to gather again
the virus was able to make a comeback
over and over we should have known that
that was coming
because every time we have had a holiday
civic holiday
or anything which encouraged gatherings
to occur we always saw
cases increase governments say experts
have not done enough to keep the virus
in check with better tools to screen in
schools
and with sufficient testing and contact
tracing the plan should have been we
lock down you drive the case numbers
down to something reasonable and you
deploy
extraordinary public health assets to
keep the numbers simmering at a low
level
backwards contact racing you find the
source of the outbreak and
on top of that rapid testing now we're
facing a new threat much like we did a
year ago
new covet variants being discovered so
far in small numbers
but this year we won't have the excuse
that we don't understand it
and didn't see it coming eric sorenson
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is this labor of love a skating
rink the petrie family made in
invaria ontario just gorgeous there are
beautiful spots all over canada please
email us
yours to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
you